♪.
PETE: WE JUST RAN IN.
WE'RE TWO DAYS AWAY FROM THE
MIDTERMS.
THERE IS A LOT AT STAKE.
WILL: LET'S BREAK DOWN THE
LATEST FOX NEWS POWER RANKINGS
BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
WE'LL LOOK AT SOME FORECASTS.
PETE: YOU WANT TO BE BRET OR
MARTHA?
I WILL BE MARTHA, YOU BE BRET.
WILL: THINK ABOUT THAT ONE FOR A
LITTLE WHILE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE HOUSE,
SEE WHAT THE FORECASTS ARE FOR
GOP VERSUS DEMOCRATIC CONTROL.
THE FORECAST ACCORDING TO
FOX NEWS IS REPUBLICANS TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
YOU CAN SEE A BEST CASE SCENARIO
FOR BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ON THIS WALL.
PETE: ABSOLUTELY.
218 WHAT YOU NEED TO GET A
MAJORITY AND BASED ON THE
FORECASTING OF POLLS AGGREGATED
THUS FAR IN THE POWER RANKINGS
IS MOST LIKELY SCENARIO IS
REPUBLICAN CONTROL.
YOU MENTIONED IT, WILL.
THE BOTTOM IS THE CURRENT,
BEST-CASE SCENARIO FOR BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, THE
KEY TAKEAWAY ON THE SIDE, EVEN
THE BEST-CASE SCENARIO POWER
RANKINGS HAS KEVIN McCARTHY AS
SPEAKER OF HOUSE.
WILL: PICKING UP SEATS WHAT WE
SEE TODAY.
IN THE REPUBLICANS BEST-CASE
SCENARIO, THAT IS OVERWHELMING.
PETE: SOME PEOPLE SAY THIS
NUMBER COULD GO HIGHER IF THERE
IS RED TSUNAMI, SOME DISTRICTS
GIVEN OREGON, MINNESOTA,
WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN, ARE IN PLAY
STATEWIDE, SOME OF THOSE HOUSE
DISTRICTS COULD, YOU COULD SEE A
NIGHT OVER 250.
NOT LIKELY BUT POSSIBLE.
WILL: LOOK AT PROJECTIONS BY THE
SENATE, PROJECTION BY FOX NEWS
DEMOCRATS HAVE 47 SEATS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE 49 SEATS WITH
FOUR IN THE COLUMN OF TOSS-UP.
THOSE STATES, PETE, ARE OVER
THERE ON THE MAP.
PETE: HERE ARE THE TOSSUPS.
HEARING A LOT ABOUT THEM.
NEVADA, ADAM LAXALT, IN ARIZONA,
BLAKE MASTERS IN A TIGHT RACE AS
MARK KELLY, WASN'T SEEN AS TIGHT
BUT TIGHTEN AD LOT.
JOHN FETTERMAN AND MEHMET OZ,
DOWN IN GEORGIA, HIS PROSPECTS
ARE LIKE THE BULLDOGS YESTERDAY
HE IS IN GOOD SHAPE.
THEY PUT A WHIPPING ON
TENNESSEE.
WILL: REPUBLICANS TAKE TWO OF
THE TOSSUPS, ACCORDING TO
PROJECTIONS THEY HAVE THE
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE.
PETE: ONLY NEED TWO OF THESE
FOUR.
BECAUSE WISCONSIN, OHIO,
NORTH CAROLINA ARE LOOKING
SOLIDLY IN THE REPUBLICAN CAMP.
WILL: RIGHT.
GOVERNORS WHICH FOCUSES ON SOME
OF THOSE SAME STATES, NEVADA,
ARIZONA, ADD TO THAT WISCONSIN,
OR GONE, YOU CAN SEE REPUBLICANS
REPUBLICANS, WELL OVER 30
GOVERNORS I BELIEVE OUT OF 50
STATES ARE REPUBLICAN.
PETE: YEAH.
WILL: MORE ON THE WAY.
PETE: SOME SURPRISES YOU SHOULD
BE ON THE LOOKOUT FOR ON
ELECTION NIGHT.
MINNESOTA WITH DR. SCOTT JENSEN
RUNNING TIGHT AGAINST WALTZ.
TUDOR DIXON IN MICHIGAN RUNNING
MUCH STRONGER CAMPAIGN THAN
PEOPLE ANTICIPATED.
IN NEW YORK, THIS WILL BE EARLY
RETURN TO LOOK AT IN NEW YORK,
IF LEE ZELDIN IS TIGHT, WHAT AN
INDICATION BE FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THE COUNTRY.
BIG ONE IN ARIZONA AS WELL.
WILL: STILL IN THE TOSS-UP
CATEGORY, KARI LAKE OUT-OF-STATE
CAMPAIGNING.
JOE BIDEN NOT GOING TO ARIZONA.
ALL INDICATIONS ARE THAT
REPUBLICANS FEEL STRONG AND
DEMOCRATS FEEL WEAK IN ARIZONA.
PETE: THE OTHER ONE IF THE STATE
OF OREGON IS YELLOW IN TOSS-UP,
ANOTHER SENSE WHERE THE
ELECTORATE IS RIGHT NOW.
WILL: LOOK AT CANDIDATES WHAT
THEY'RE SPENDING ON THE DEMOCRAT
SIDE TO WIN OR FIGHT AGAINST ALL
ODDS TO WIN THESE SEATS.
RAFAEL WARNOCK IS BIG SPENDER,
76, ALMOST $76 MILLION FOR
RAFAEL WARNOCK.
ARIZONA, MARK KELLY,
$73 MILLION.
PETE: THAT IS A LOT OF MONEY,
$68 MILLION TO GET THUMPED.
VAL DEMMINGS WILL SPEND THAT
MUCH IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
ALREADY IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA,
SHE WILL GET BEAT.
FETTERMAN, MORE MONEY POURING IN
FOR HIM, JOE BIDEN AND
BARACK OBAMA JED IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THE TIM RYAN CAMPAIGN RAISED
44 MILLION, AGAIN ANOTHER
CAMPAIGN LOOKS LIKELY TO GO FOR
JD VANCE.
I WILL NOTE IN A LOT OF THESE
STATES DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING
AGAINST REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
THAT THEY SAID THEY WANTED TO
RUN AGAINST.
WILL: YES.
FUNDED BY DEMOCRAT,.
PETE: HERSCHEL WALKER, BLAKE
MASTERS, KARI LAKE, MEHMET OZ,
JD VANCE, DONALD TRUMP ADVANCED
CANDIDATES THEY SAID WERE
UNELECTABLE.
THOSE CANDIDATES ARE ABOUT TO
WIN.
MANY CASES DEMOCRATS GAVE TO THE
CANDIDATES.
WILL: THEY WERE SO CONFIDENT,
THOSE THESE QUOTE, UNQUOTE
THEFTS TO DEMOCRACY WOULD LOSE
TO A DEMOCRAT TO HELP FUND THE
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
PETE: THEY'RE ABOUT TO WIN.
HOW MUCH OF THE CLOSING ARGUMENT
OF DEMOCRATS IS ON ABORTION?
WILL: 45% OF SPENDING FOR
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES ON THE
MESSAGE OF ABORTION.
LOOK AT THOSE STATES WHERE
THEY'RE FOCUSING THAT MESSAGE.
PETE: I WAS IN ARIZONA THIS
WEEKEND A DINER IN, INFLATION IN
ARIZONA, 13%.
HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
YOU'RE FEELING IT.
45% OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ON THE
TELEVISION SCREEN UP TO
$100 MILLION IS ABOUT ABORTION.
WILL: I WANT TO GO TO THE LAST
WALL REALLY QUICKLY WHERE BIDEN,
OBAMA, TRUMP ARE SPENDING TIME.
PETE, HERE IS WHAT STANDS OUT TO
ME REALLY QUICKLY, OBVIOUSLY
DONALD TRUMP, TO SOME EXTENT
BARACK OBAMA ARE SPENDING TIMES
IN THOSE TOSS-UP STATES --
PETE: YEP.
WILL: NONE, PENNSYLVANIA THE
ONLY ONE THAT JOE BIDEN, THOSE
CANDIDATES DON'T WANT TO BE
AROUND JOE BIDEN.